this is Lagos
the most populated city in Africa
it's the financial capital of Nigeria
the continent's largest economy
more than 15 million people live here
that's twice the size of the next
biggest African Mega City
what was once a small coastal town is
now a heaving Metropolis attracting
economic migrants from all over West
Africa but as the City's population
keeps growing you can really build an
infrastructure Buckle under the pressure
earlier this year the state expanded its
population control policy
granting access to free contraceptives
at local clinics
geared towards underserved communities
first they need to be convinced so six
children and you you potentially are
going to have more
um
help me
bearing children is closely linked to a
woman's worth
and for those who can't deliver there
are consequences do you feel pressured
to have children soon
what kind of pressure are you feeling
such as insults
what are people saying to you
but I'm useless yeah they have not yet
seen anything
at least 95 million people here live
below the poverty line and as families
keep growing there are more mouths to be
fed so how are you able to provide for
your children for your five children
[Music]
organizations are working with Community
leaders to bridge the gap in Awareness
an education that comes second to
tradition
but can the women here make the decision
themselves about what they want to do
around having children oh it is not
possible because when we came there they
said they cannot do anything without
their husbands okay because the husband
is the head of the house you have to
follow the instructions
so the husband dictates whether a child
the mother has the child whether they
even decide to use any of the
contraceptives
why do people want to keep having more
children
culture
tradition
it's it goes a long way to to it plays a
long part
just on the other side of the Lagos
Lagoon is makoko
people have been living here in makoka
for over 100 years but as climate change
intensifies and the world's population
surges this growing Community is one of
the most at risk of demolition by the
government and lack of affordable living
space but also rising sea levels I could
see this place disappear
this community keeps growing but there's
just not enough space
taiwo is the son of mokoko's Chief and
runs a school and orphanage here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we have uh 200 000 people living on
water and we have 200 000 people living
on land and right now the kids the
children are more than the adults yeah
in this economy right now to be sincere
no most people in my coconut they don't
even want to have a child anymore
yeah
Lagos is just one of many cities facing
extreme population pressure and
habitable land is becoming harder and
harder to find with 8 billion people now
living on Earth the most vulnerable will
be the most overwhelmed
Sky News Lagos